so Eric's wall well swallow well who is
technically a presidential candidate and
also I think maybe he's a congressman or
something like that I don't know
anyway he tweeted this last night he
said do you know how many times the word
woman is mentioned in the Constitution
zero that is unacceptable women must be
equally represented and equally
protected now okay this is this is just
more striking evidence that Eric swallow
oil is I'm trying to put this delicately
a more on the word woman does not appear
in the Constitution that's true neither
does the word man that's because the
Constitution is a legal document which
it enumerates the powers and
responsibilities of the government it
doesn't get into specifics about man
woman boy girl doesn't doesn't say those
words they're actually a whole bunch of
words that are not in the Constitution I
mean comparatively speaking almost every
word is not in the Constitution really
there are only a few words that are used
when you compare two guys I mean the
word the word futon isn't in the
Constitution banjo kangaroo shoe zealous
flabby parmesan waddle globe tree lamp
door I mean there are so many words that
are not in Constitution I mean seriously
like I said the word parmesan is not in
there I I we have spaghetti once a week
in my family and we have spaghetti night
you know and and i always use parmesan
millions of americans use parmesan yet
this is not acknowledged in the
constitution which is despicable
despicable I say so very good point
actually I take it back
Eric swallows not a [ __ ] an excellent
point I think that he made all right um
a lot to talk about but but first you
know it's spring time that's the time of
year when seeds grow into flowers and
and and you grow up financially at least
your family needs protection
if something happens to you and that
mean
means that you need life insurance and
thankfully policy genius makes it easy
to get that financial security without
all the growing pains policy genius is
the easy way to buy life insurance
online in just two minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price two minutes is when you
think about how complicated this whole
process can seem sometimes if you're not
using policy genius I mean two minutes
is piece of cake so once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork all the red tape they'll do
that for you no Commission's no hidden
fees not getting tricked into anything
here just financial protection and peace
of mind with no strings attached and
policy genius doesn't just simplify life
insurance they also make it easy to
compare and buy home insurance auto
insurance disability insurance they'll
take care of all that for you so next
time you stop to smell the roses pull
out your phone and head to policy
genius.com policy genius spring is here
kick it off by nipping life insurance in
the bud all right okay speaking of
tweeting I did want to mention that the
President of the United States tweeted
like sixty five times this morning not
hyperbole he tweeted sixty five times I
mean a number of those were retweets but
but but still he went on a tear because
some people claim that firefighters are
gonna vote for Joe Biden and Trump
believes that firefighters are going to
vote for him so he went through and
retweeted about fifty different random
people who say that that no actually
firefighters like Donald Trump not Joe
Biden now look this is what I always say
okay you know I'm a broken record I'll
say it again if you're a die-hard Trump
supporter I think you need to try to see
this through the lens of someone who is
not a die-hard Trump supporter because
most people aren't which isn't a knock
on Trump I mean most people are not
diehard supporters of any particular
politician right the diehard supporters
of any politician are always going to be
in the minority no one has ever had no
politician has ever had 51% of the
population as diehard fans of those
there's it's just it doesn't happen so
what that means is there aren't enough
diehard fans of Trump
to get him elected again they're the
diehard fans are not the ones who got
him elected the first time you know it's
because he attracted a lot of people who
are kind of in the middle so you're
gonna need the non diehards too and the
nine but non diehards are not nearly as
excited about all the tweeting as you
might be if you're a die-hard in fact
the non diehards get the impression that
the president cares more about trolling
on Twitter than he does about governing
the non diehards also believe that you
as a die-hard would definitely criticize
literally any other politician who spent
all day tweeting especially if it was
like Barack Obama or someone like that
so if Trump is going to win in 2020 and
I hope he does he's going to need to
start operating in a way that does not
just that does not just appeal to the
diehard fans while we're pulsing
everybody else he's gonna need to
broaden his appeal just a little bit I
mean that's my advice I know it won't be
followed by the way I I looked it up
right before I went on the air just to
see what the polling says on this and it
turns out that I'm what do you know
exactly right from from political it
says nearly half of voters 46% in a
Politico slash morning consult poll say
that yes Trump's Twitter use hurts his
re-election campaign more than twice the
number who say his direct to voters
Twitter account is an asset 7 and 10
voters say Trump uses Twitter too much
while 14% say he uses it the right
amount 1% say that he doesn't tweet
enough okay but but again a small
minority now this does matter okay I
know you're gonna say oh it doesn't
matter - it does matter because it's the
kind of thing that helps to form a
visceral impression of a person and the
visceral impression matters a lot and
the visceral impression that a lot of
people have of Trump is negative that's
just the fact whether or not you know
whether or not you like it doesn't
matter it's the fact and I think when
you encourage the President to do more
of the thing that helps to generate that
viscerally negative impression you're
encouraging him to lose which isn't good
all right Attorney General William bar
will testify today before the Senate
Judiciary Committee and this is great
because it's been you know a couple of
days
said someone testified in front of a
committee and I've really been jonesing
for another fix I don't know about you I
you know I I need to get these Senate
committees I need I need to see more of
them this is what I live for
right don't we all but in the lead-up to
that testimony the I was being sarcastic
I feel like I need to clarify these days
in the lead-up to testimony the
Washington Post published a report
claiming that robert muller complained
to bar about bars summary of his report
a summary that as you remember Barr
released weeks before the full report
was actually released now of course the
media and the left they've gone crazy
over this claiming that you know Barr is
in on it bars a cover-up artist bar has
to be impeached - now bar has to be
arrested he's obstructing justice he's
blah blah blah he's a criminal so on and
so forth the headline on CNN says
William bar is in deep trouble The
Huffington Post said bars spin too much
for Muller then Joe Scarborough you can
always count on him to have the most
nuanced and thoughtful take on a subject
he said breaking the Attorney General
actively engaged in a cover-up was
called on it and continued to cover up
the truth about Trump's obstruction of
justice now the problem with all this is
that it isn't true which I know for the
media they don't really consider that to
be a problem when they're reporting
something but I think it is because the
same report in The Washington Post
report that very same one clarifies that
Muller did not think that Barr lied or
mischaracterized or Mis written
misrepresented anything so ironically
it's you know the media is
mischaracterizing this by saying that
Muller claimed that he was
mischaracterized
mahler in fact admitted that bar did not
say anything that was inaccurate
he was upset rather by the media
coverage he did take issue with with
with the summary itself but not in a way
that he was accusing him of lying this
is what he hears in part what Muller
said he said the Summerlin the summary
letter the department sent to Congress
and release to the public late in the
afternoon of March 24th did not fully
capture the context nature and substance
of this office's work and conclusions
there is now public confusion about
critical aspects of the results of our
investigation this threatens to
undermine a central purpose for which
the department appointed a special
counsel to ensure full public confidence
in the outcome of the investigations he
then requested that the full report be
released and he suggested that you know
he suggested a few redactions that
should be made and then guess what the
full report was released and you can go
and read it right now it's out there you
can go read it the idea that this is a
cover-up when the report is out there
for anyone to read is of course
ridiculous so the left is once again way
way way way overstating the case and
they're hurting themselves in the
process because they could say you know
they could just say well looks like
Muller you know would have preferred
that the whole report was released he
didn't he didn't he didn't like a few of
the aspects that he thought it was you
know it didn't get the full context and
that's true okay so it you you could
just say that but that isn't a bombshell
and everything has to be a bombshell
these days
everything has to be huge breaking news
oh my God we're all gonna die right
that's what everything has to be there
there are no boring news stories anymore
I don't know if you've noticed that
nothing is allowed to be boring
everything has to be dramatic and and
and catastrophic and I think we have to
understand that about about the media
that for the it's important to
understand the media's motivations that
not for them just about hating Trump I
mean they do hate Trump obviously but
that's not all that this is about it's
also and I would say primarily it's
about news as entertainment it's about
getting people to watch the news like
they're watching house of cards and and
it's it's you know they want people to
follow along with the news like they're
binging something on Netflix and that's
why I'm not really at all convinced that
these media people really do want Trump
to lose in 2020 in fact I'm pretty
convinced they don't because he's been
great for them they've got this whole
fantasy narrative going about him this
whole storyline and it's great for
ratings they lose if he loses so I yeah
I don't think they want him to be voted
out which is why it's probably not a
coincidence that they're everything
they're doing is only helping him when
they try to make they take something
like this they they misrepresent it they
make it into a whole big bombshell story
embarrass themselves over and over and
over again it only makes Trump look
better by comparison and it makes people
arrive at the conclusion that okay well
there's obviously there's no there's no
smoke or fire here I mean char this is
this is a you know and then if the media
ever does get their hands on an actual
scandal or you know evidence of actual
malfeasance of some kind that's gonna be
the boy who cried wolf no one's gonna
believe it so I don't yeah now I'm not
saying that they're that they're
conspiring to get him elected I just
think that if the media really wanted to
work hard to make sure that Trump didn't
get reelected I think they'd be doing
things a little bit differently but for
them it's all about ratings and Trump
still is is a bonanza for them for
ratings
I mean just look at just look at MSNBC's
ratings in the in the Obama years
compared to what it's been in the Trump
years it's been great for them
so it's there their need for ratings
combined with their hatred of Trump and
all of that together leads to this all
right this is interesting from CBN
reading from CBN right now it says four
schools in Northern Virginia claim that
there are quote thousands of students in
Virginia public schools who identify as
transgender and they should be allowed
to use whatever bathroom they choose the
Washington Post reports that the
Alexander Arlington Falls Church in
Fairfax County School Boards filed a
friend of the court brief on behalf of
Gavin grim a biological girl who sued
her school board in in Virginia in 2015
after being denied access to the boys
restroom Grimm claimed that the school
violated Title 9 and the Equal
Protection Clause of the Constitution
and the case made it the Supreme Court
but was returned to a lower court after
the Trump administration abandoned the
Obama era rule on transgender students
and then it goes on from there
the thing that I'm latching on to here
the thing that's that jumps out at me is
it says thousands of transgenders
thousands now what do we do with a
number like that what what does that
mean it seems to me that it must mean
one of two things either the number is
completely bogus which of course is
possible or it means that transgenderism
is a fad and kids identify as gender
fluid or transgender because that's what
their friends are doing and that's what
society encourages and it's the
fashionable trendy thing now it could
really mean you know it could mean both
of those things but it has to mean one
or one or both because if transgenderism
is a real thing if it's naturally
occurring then there's no reason why
there should be a spike in
transgenderism which happens to
coincidentally coincide with media
attention to transgenderism like if
there was a rash of media coverage about
people with red hair if all of a sudden
we were all
talking about gingers all the time then
you know what you would not see a spike
in red-haired people being born the
percentage of red-haired people has I
would imagine remain basically static
throughout human history because it's
not affected by society that's not the
case with transgenderism in fact there
was a study done on this a couple of
years ago the CNN report says a team
examined data from a 2016 survey of
almost eighty one thousand Minnesota
students in the ninth and eleventh
grades
nearly 2200 of those students about 2.7
percent answered yes to the question do
you consider yourself transgender gender
queer gender fluid or unsure of your
gender identification that's a big jump
from a UCLA study which was published in
January 2017 and estimated that 0.7
percent of American teens aged 13 to 17
identifies transgender that study was
based on government data on adults
collected by 27 US states in 2014 to
2015 so according to that the number of
gender fluid teens has nearly tripled in
a couple of years tripled I mean why is
that again if this is if this is a
naturally occurring thing if you can
actually be transgender because of you
know your physiology because of how you
were born if you're born that way well
then why would you happen to see this
spike of course it doesn't make any
sense and the reason why we see it is
because it has become fashionable in the
mean time and so kids are if and and by
the way fashionable not just for the
kids but for parents too so you've got
high school kids impressionable high
school kids who are looking around and
seeing that this is this is the new
popular trendy thing and then you've got
parents also who are seeing the same
thing and they decide that oh we're
going to raise our kid to be transgender
that's what's happening here you know
the leftist like to laugh and say that
you know when we criticize all of this
transgender hysteria they'll say oh what
do you think we're trying to turn your
kid trans it into a transgender well
yeah actually that is what I think that
is basically what you're trying to do
and that is what you have succeeded in
doing for apparently thousands of kids
all right
the United Methodist Church is being
protested in Nebraska because it
affirmed biblical views on sexuality a
group of teens now will not be taking
part in the Omaha First United Methodist
Church confirmation ritual because the
church considers the homosexual act to
be sinful and they reaffirm that view
recently so in a letter this group of
teenagers they wrote in part we are
concerned that if we join at this time
we will be sending a message that we
approve of this decision the decision to
affirm biblical sexual morality we want
to be clear that while we love our
congregation we believe the United
Methodist policies on lgbtq+ clergy and
same-sex marriage are immoral we are not
standing just for ourselves we are
standing for every single member of the
LGBTQ community who is hurting right now
because because we were raised in this
church we believe that if we all stand
together as a whole we can make a
difference so you notice that as usual
those who are advocating for LGBT
inclusion or you know whatever they they
don't bother making a theological
argument have you noticed that the
argument is always based around their
personal beliefs and convictions they
always frame the argument as oh well
this is hateful this is bigoted they
don't bother trying to cite chapter and
verse or to make any argument on a
theological basis at all and in that of
course is a problem because the Bible
does clearly condemn the homosexual act
whether you like it or not repeatedly it
does also define marriage as between a
man and
it does so at the very beginning in
Genesis and then Jesus reaffirms Andrey
asserts that definition in the Gospels
matthew 19:4 go check it out for
yourself now if you're going to say that
there should be gay marriage in the
church and there should be gay clergy
and there should be gay acceptance and
all of that well you have to do
something with those verses because
they're the verses are there the
teachings are there and you have to
address them you need to have some kind
of answer for them right you can't just
pretend they don't exist I mean if
you're an atheist then sure you can wave
them off and say well who cares but if
you're retaining your Christian identity
or trying to retain it then that option
is not available to you you can't wave
it off you have to have some answer for
it and the people in this camp they have
no answer they don't bother answering it
now the most on the rare occasion that
someone who's advocating for LGBT
inclusion in the church and gay marriage
from a Christian perspective on the rare
occasion that someone like that does try
a theological argument well they they
can't they don't make a a positive
theological argument like saying well
the Bible actually promotes
homosexuality in gay marriage they they
don't do that because they know they
can't you just can't make a case for it
but instead they'll try to look at
individual verses that seem to condemn
the homosexual act and there's they'll
say well no that's not really about
homosexual generally that's about
prostitution or that's about you know
any sex outside of marriage or it's
about paganism and so on and there are
there are a few verses in the Bible
where you can maybe make that argument
but you certainly can't do it with all
the verses and what you what you
definitely cannot qualify out of
existence would be these very clear
passages right at the
the beginning of the Old Testament and
right in the Gospels that define
marriage there's just no getting around
that it's right there and if you believe
that God is omniscient then you can't
say well yeah it says marriage between a
man and a woman but but you know it
doesn't say anything about gay marriage
and so maybe they did what God didn't
didn't know that this would be an issue
so I didn't think to mention it that of
course makes no sense
so it seems to me that the only way to
kind of diffuse those verses is to
diffuse the entire Bible and say that
well you know it's not really the Word
of God at all
so we don't have to abide by it and as I
said as an atheist you can do that but
as a Christian you can't so if you want
to be a Christian you you have to accept
that whether you like it or not it's
right there all right before we get to
emails I need to play this for you
there's a there's a Sonic the Hedgehog
movie coming out apparently coming to
theaters soon for some reason and the
trailer was released and it's it's maybe
the worst trailer I've ever seen it
might really be the worst movie trailer
of all time it's so cataclysmically bad
that I think you just have to see it if
you haven't yet so watch this
what
gotta go fast
20 minutes ago an energy surge knocked
out power across the entire Pacific
Northwest this needs someone who could
figure out exactly what we're deep with
you're not suggest my wife think you're
suggesting we have no choice
what are you in charge here yes I am I'm
wrong mommy charge allow me to clarify
in a sequential e ranked hierarchy based
on level of critical importance the
disparity between us is too vast to
quantify agent stone the doctor thinks
you're basic listen pal I don't know if
you realize no sorry major what was your
name Ben nobody cares
[Music]
meow okay we'll just cut it off there I
don't need to watch the entire that goes
on for another two minutes there are so
many questions I have like for instance
why well why why are we doing this what
is it about Sonic the Hedgehog I mean
well what is it about Sonic than the
video game Sonic that made a screen
writer say oh well that's a great story
we need to mine that story for all
weekend also is there a man standing
offset pointing a gun at Jim Carrey or
was a family member kidnapped or
something and the kidnapped er kidnapper
demanded that he star in Sonic the
Hedgehog or he'll never see his family
member again there's got to be an
explanation because I don't understand I
mean Jim Carrey Hays fallen off recently
but he could still probably star in any
movie he wanted to and he chooses Sonic
the Hedgehog although I guess of course
Jim Carrey hasn't been in a good movie
in like 20 years 20 years ago it seems
that he just died decided he pledged 20
years ago that he's only going to star
in crap movies from then on out and he
has admirably remained loyal to that
pledge we got to give him credit for
that
so Wow Sonic the Hedgehog which you know
it may be so bad that it's actually good
there's a chance
so it might be worth watching when it
comes out all right let's go to emails
Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt well
show at gmail.com this one is from Matt
says would you apply the same moral
culpability argument which I made
yesterday on the show backward as you do
Ford for example biblical immodesty
slash gluttony or immoral but in today's
society these sins are generally
considered less serious than they were
in the past
would you consider gluttons Ortiz's less
morally culpable today than in the past
great thought exercise either way keep
up the good work yeah we were talking
about the moral culpability yesterday on
the show of people in the past for
things like racism even slavery which
were both totally accepted part and
taken for granted as facts of life for
much of human history across the entire
world and so I would argue that for our
ancestors they have less moral
culpability for being racist than we do
today so would that apply today as well
well I would say it does I mean the
point is that every society has certain
sins certain moral foibles that are
taken for granted that are just a given
and and not seen as as being immoral
even though they are it's not that
they're not immoral because people don't
see it as immoral it still is immoral
but but people but people don't see it
and so a person can accept that behavior
and they can adopt that behavior more
out of a sort of intellectual laziness
than out of abject evil on their part
they're just going with the flow you
know and that's not an excuse and it
doesn't mitigate the the guilt down to
nothing certainly there still is guilt
but it does mitigate it to some extent I
would think I think the fact is this and
it's a sad fact that there are few
people at any given moment in history
who really have the wherewithal and the
insight and the wisdom and the
intelligence moral intelligence to see
beyond their own time and to see evil as
evil
just because it is even if everyone else
accepts him that it would seem is a
relatively rare quality which is why I
mean it is a fascinating thing to think
about that for thousands of years
basically everyone in the world was
racist and and and nobody thought not to
be I mean the idea of not being racist
which is not in didn't get incoming
anyone's head they just took it for
granted it was like tribalism they they
saw people that look different from them
that lived in different places at a
different culture and they said yeah
those people are you know inferior to us
of course they are now nowadays it's
it's we can't even most of us anyway
at least in the West we can't even
understand that because we can't even we
can't wrap our head around it right
because we take it absolutely for
granted that all people are equal and
dignity and Worth and that the color of
your skin has no bearing on your worth
as a person we just take that for
granted as well we should but that is a
very new thing
in human history it only recently became
obvious that racism is bad like really
recently up until you know the last 60
or 70 years it was not so obvious which
I think when we recognized that fact
it should cause us to stop and think now
wait a second what are okay so this is a
moral evil that everybody in the world
take took for granted for thousands of
years I wonder what moral evils we are
taking for granted today and then we can
go and do an inventory of all the things
that we take for granted and we think
are normal and just re-evaluate them and
I think it is that actually okay I think
that's a self-assessment that we all
should perform let's see this is from
kaya says Matt I'm listening to Monday's
show as you discussed this controversy
over Robert Ely
I won't draw a non drone on and on about
it but I'm wondering if there's hope
that people will ever stop being so
stupid why can't people see that we can
call Lee one of the greatest generals
and also discussed his downfalls of of
morality why is that so hard to
understand thank you for helping my
sanity on a daily basis kaya
I am plagued by this question myself why
are people so stupid it's a good
question important question it really is
you could write volumes trying to
dissect this question there's no easy
answer for it
there are many culprits I think there
are many stupid to fiying forces at work
and if I had to sum it up I would say
that people are getting stupid or people
are stupid and getting stupider and that
is definitely happening because I think
that our brains are atrophying from lack
of use I think that's kind of what's
happening intellectual laziness leads to
stupidity intellectual laziness is not
itself stupidity you can be
intellectually lazy and also a genius
just like you could be physically lazy
and also physically fit at the same time
but the two conditions cannot coexist
forever or probably won't eventually the
lack of activity will translate into
obesity in the one case and idiocy and
the other the problem is that we don't
really have to think in modern culture
like you can get away with not thinking
you can get away with living your whole
life basically on a day-to-day basis and
not really thinking about anything
because there are so many things that
can do your thinking for you you can
always ask Siri or Alexa if you have any
question you can Google whatever if you
want to you know if you want to learn
about something you just google it you
can look at Wikipedia but you're not
really learning you're just getting
random
of information and stocking them in your
head so that you can spit them out
whenever the subject comes out but you
had you you haven't actually learned
anything you've just you've just
memorized a few key points it's not
learning that's not thinking and as far
as thinking about issues and
controversies and politics and so on
well there's a whole army of pundits
like me who will happily think for you
and tell you what to think and not
because we ourselves are great thinkers
no we are part of a hive mind a pundit
class and we just say whatever our hive
happens to be saying we unthinkingly
repeat talking points and then you
unthinkingly absorb them and nobody is
thinking about anything and if that
night you ever feel you know if you're
sitting there at night and you're a
little bored or something and you feel
oh my gosh a thought coming on you know
you actually you start to feel yourself
thinking about something well and you
feel like you're teetering dangerously
close to developing an original thought
on a subject well then you can always
turn on Netflix and binge for six hours
until your brain is leaking out of your
ears and you could put a stop to it that
way you never really have to have a
quiet moment of contemplation you never
have to have silence or stillness in
your life you never will by necessity
find yourself in an environment that is
conducive to thinking and of course we
don't read anymore either we read means
and we read tweets and we read Wikipedia
articles but we don't read entire books
and not reading books but trying to be
smart is like trying to get in shape but
never going for a jog it's just
it probably won't you could try it but
it probably won't work so we don't read
we stare at screens we have all the
answers spoon-fed to us we have no
silence no contemplation and and then we
turn into nota morons I think enormous
morons it really it's it's you know if
you
oh and we've been talking about the
civil war on the show over the this.path
the past few days so speaking of the
Civil War and I you know it's as I have
mentioned I am interested in it I won't
call myself a Civil War buff I'm not
quite at that level I'm more of a I
would I would say I'm an enthusiast
which that's a rung below before to get
to buff and then from buff you get to
expert so I've got a while to go before
I get to expert but anyway I am
interested in it and one thing that I
find fascinating is all of these guys
you know these generals and even the the
infantry soldiers they would you know
they didn't have phones back then or
emails so they would they would write
letters back home to their wives and
their mothers and fathers and everything
and so if you if you read the letters
that these guys would write and these
were you know I mean the the generals
were most of them well educated but
these words scholars were talking about
and it's certainly the you know just
average soldier it was was many of them
were not really educated at all but what
strikes me when I read when I read these
letters of these really kind of average
men intellectually for their time very
eloquent they just they very thoughtful
very eloquent they would they would be
they would be sharing these these really
penetrating insights into the nature of
war and battle and and they would just
write it in a letter and ship it off to
their send it off to their to their wife
or whatever and so I think it gives you
an idea of how deeply people used to
think about things and how eloquent they
were kind of naturally and how good they
were at using language and in describing
things and we can't do any of that
anymore like if we want to describe our
emotions these days we what do we do it
we use an emoji we use like a smiley
face
we have devolved back into cavemen
riding high road
on the cave wall you know if we want to
say we're happy instead of instead of
describing our happiness like a like
like a like a man writing his letter
back to his wife after a big battle he
would he would he would describe his
elation and these eloquent terms but we
what we do is we just send a smiley face
which is basically saying me happy
smiley face me happy every time you send
an emoji that's what you're doing me sad
tears me sad that's how we communicate
now and part of the problem is if you
think about it people that lived in the
19th century or the 17th century or the
15th century they they there was a lot
of quiet in their life they couldn't
just spill every waking moment with
noise because they didn't have TVs in
the internet and all that so they would
have many moments in their life of just
quiet like at night what do you think
what do you think of an average person
did in 1840 when it was you know 7
o'clock at night and they were back from
from work in the fields or whatever and
dinner had been served and what do they
do there was a lot of just kind of like
sitting around they'd read a book they'd
talk they'd I mean they just had that
moment there's moments of reflection
that we don't have anymore all right
so that was a 20 minute answer you
probably weren't expecting that let's
say I'll read one more ok I had a short
one but now I can't find it now this is
from
trick I don't think I've done this one
before is this future future supreme
overlord and ruthless dictator of the
world I your humble and future servant
have a question for you I listen to your
show every day and notice you speak
about the importance of religion I
understand the importance of community
and morals but you don't need religion
to have those things did I answer this
question I think I did
this is professionalism folks all right
well do this I didn't get answered this
one from Rebecca hi Matt I really enjoy
your show I want to say thank you for
doing what you do I have a question for
you on today's show you talked about
your stance on the death penalty and
mentioned that you have questions about
whether or not society should ask
someone to put someone else to death I
have to ask isn't that exactly what we
ask of our military every day someone on
death row has at least been convicted of
a horrible crime against society whereas
someone fighting on the side of our
enemy may never have committed any crime
at all how is it acceptable to ask so
many to take the lives of people who
usually have done not done them any harm
and yet give pause to the idea of
someone being asked to end the life of a
person who has been convicted of
committing a horrible crime against
society it is true that war does take
its toll on those who are asked to fight
it but as the wife of a retired Green
Beret I can assure you that not all of
our soldiers are returning home
irreparably damaged I mentioned this
only as a point that being asked to take
the life of another person does not mean
the destruction of one spiritual mental
and emotional well-being I'd be very
interested in hearing your thoughts on
this yeah I talked to I think last week
about the death penalty I said I'm in
favor of the death penalty but the one
hang-up I have the one reservation is
and this is something that I don't hear
people to address often when it comes to
this subject I'm concerned about the
psychological damage and spiritual
damage that's done to the people who are
tasked with carrying out the execution I
think I think it and maybe you could
argue that that is a job that nobody is
equipped to do or handle and thus it's a
job that society should not ask anyone
to do and if we can't ask anyone to do
that job then that means that it's
job that can't be done so we can't we
shouldn't be executing people you know
I'm not entirely convinced by that
argument myself like I said I'm in favor
of the death penalty but it is a you
know it is something that does trouble
me and so that's what Rebecca's
responding to and you make a good point
Rebecca certainly war does have a
profound impact on those who are tasked
with fighting it but as you say I don't
think it's guaranteed to do irreparable
damage and I don't think that it's the
kind of job that society can't ask
anyone to do
clearly we need some people to do this
job just as we need people to deal with
death and misery in other contexts as
policemen or Shock Trauma doctors or
EMTs or whatever else but I would argue
that there's a fundamental difference
between all of these jobs and the job of
an executioner on death row
the difference is first of all the aim
of the job so doctors and EMTs and
police officers they are supposed to be
preserving life in that capacity they
deal with death but they don't deal
death
they aren't dealers of death well
abortionists are and they but they
aren't they don't count as doctors for
the most part they aren't now even in
the military and I mean this is police
officers also what have do sometimes
have to shoot people right and in a
military obviously that involves in
combat shooting people but and in this
shooting is done with the intent of
killing the enemy obviously but the
overall point of combat is or should be
to defend something so you're defending
your country you're defending freedom
you're defending the innocent in a just
war now a lot of wars have been
conducted that have nothing to do with
defending anything and those are bad
wars but in a just ward a good war the
aim is to preserve life and so that's
what soldiers are doing just like that's
what police officers are doing now you
could argue that the executioner in some
roundabout way is defending society or
preserving life but it's a very
roundabout way because at the end of the
day
a the person being strapped to the
gurney is no longer a threat to anyone
with the way that executions are done
these days he's probably been sitting in
a cage for 15 or 20 years he hasn't been
a threat to some want to anyone for
decades he is now basically a neutered
dog who's who's you know just in a cage
and being fed a few times a day and and
and that's what he is he is not in that
moment a threat to anybody so the point
of the execution is just to kill him to
get rid of him the executioner deals
death in a way that seems much more
direct and much less obscured and much
less self defensive than the soldier or
the police officer or any other similar
job that you could name so it does it
does seem different to me it's it's just
not the same and I say this is someone
who's never killed anybody you know I've
never been an executioner I've never
been a soldier but it seems to me that
there is a difference between shooting
somebody often from a distance on a
battlefield in the midst of combat
someone who is shooting at you as well
there's a difference between that and
taking an unarmed neutered caged person
strapping them to a gurney and injecting
poison into their veins and so I think
that probably the people who are doing
that the latter thing I think they are
going to be harmed by it psychologically
in ways that maybe these other people
would not be and and so that is again
it's it does it doesn't convince me to
be against the death penalty but it is a
consideration that I find troubling all
right we'll leave it there
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed I'm Michael Knowles
host of the Michael Noel's show
Venezuela descends into further chaos as
people starve and tanks crush protesters
but socialists in the u.s. like Bernie
Sanders and AOC won't admit that
Venezuela is their utopia we will
examine that we'll talk about Bill bar
before the Senate and we'll talk about
how professors are trying to turn
pedophilia into a normal activity check
it out at daily wire.com